so what is toxic feminine femininity
well i mean so i don't mean to jump
ahead of ourselves but i mean i did
bring up amber heard right i mean i
you know so she's toxic when when we
when we think about toxic masculinity
they say that it's when you take things
that are traditionally masculine virtues
like maybe toughness or competitiveness
and you take them to a twisted extreme
right and so with women if you think
about it in in
spanish they have something called
marianismo and it's the opposite of
machismo so machismo is obviously we all
know what machismo is marianismo would
be almost like the kind of a counterpart
to that which is where you know there's
this
extreme reliance on you know kind of a
victim
role right and with the amber herd thing
as well it was very interesting because
from a criminal psychology standpoint
attractive women will always fare better
in a courtroom than an unattractive
woman unless
it is shown that she used her
attractiveness to in some way carry off
the crime and then her
attractiveness will statistically turn
against her interesting so about toxic
femininity then that would be the case
of a woman who uses her femininity her
you know beguiling feminine self in a
way that um you know twists and
manipulates and deceives people and i
think part of why they will never
acknowledge that is because to do so is
to
understand and acknowledge that there
are certain benefits to being a woman i
think a lot of what we are seeing in
modern
in modern western culture the failures
are due to masculinity being gutted and
purged which is creating this imbalance
where
a massive outgrowth of femininity
becomes toxic and there's no strong men
to rebalance
so like you mentioned you all of a
sudden have the oppression olympics
everyone has to be a victim
toxic femininity is taking over
absolutely even to the point where they
have to make it up and you know what
it's not good for the women either i
mean i've sat with women in my office as
a clinical psychologist that have
expressed profound shame women you know
that are in their mid late 20s that say
you know back in college i cheated on my
boyfriend and i felt really bad about it
and i you know kind of said it was date
rape and you know i and and they they
they realized you know years later that
that they basically ruined somebody's
life um but at the time as soon as they
even kind of utter the words you know
well i he he he made me or whatever then
all of a sudden they activate this you
know big support network around them and
i've actually also spoken for an
organization called face families
advocating for campus equality and they
they try to assist young men who are
being what's called title ix at schools
now where it's it's a verb you know that
a woman can just say oh well you know he
raped me or you know he harassed me and
in many cases the man is actually
removed from school
immediately while the school does some
kind of a kangaroo court thing so toxic
femininity this is why the johnny depp
amber heard thing was such a big deal
for a lot of people i'm not gonna say
for everybody for a lot of people it was
just celebrity gossip but you had a guy
who was accused and he won
all of this me too stuff was just like
you had aziz ansari do you remember that
he had a bad date and no one was like it
was terrible so they try to go after him
it's it's insane that was insane because
i remember the woman said basically like
i went to his house i you know i think
she said she went down on him then she
gave him a [ __ ] you know what i mean
like and and and there there was no talk
of him like forcing her to stay i mean
again like i think she like
of her own free will she mentioned how
he was like really nice and saying
things like you know we don't have to or
something like that yeah and i mean this
is why it actually hurts women i mean
and on the surface of it it looks like
oh look you know when women are wielding
this incredible power you know but but
the truth is is that it actually hurts
women it it infantilizes women it
suggests that we're not actually capable
of going out and having some drinks and
making our own choices and you know
being able to stand by them it's
actually hurting women right i would i
would argue part of what all of this
comes from is our society's insistence
upon oppressing the innate or
suppressing the innate understanding
that sex is a special thing so people
think they can just go out and do it
meaninglessly and then they regret it
but because the culture constantly
signals to them that there's nothing
wrong with doing it they wonder why do i
feel bad about this experience and i
think one conclusion they could draw
from it is there must have been some
coercive element here i must not have
chosen this because i've regretted this
and i've actually seen people say oh
yeah no if you regretted it then it was
coerced which is an insane thing to say
i will say the interesting thing about
it is in
modern culture we associate hookups with
regret
that in tv shows and movies it's like
they wake up the next day like oh man
then you also have the walk of shame of
course after someone hooks up in college
and they're walking out of the dorm or
or the the fred or sorority house it's
like a shameful thing and i'm like
that's really weird for
us a society that's trying to tell
people it's it's it's shameless it's
prideful but then in every facet people
feel
something negative about the experience
it's so interesting to me that they
still feel shame i still firmly believe
that shame holds a very important role
in society and people just choose to
ignore it and one of the things i've
constantly said is that every sex scene
in every movie is completely unnecessary
because our culture does not believe
that sex means anything what's the point
of having sex you're just doing a thing
who cares are you deeply in love oh yeah
probably not i just watched the boys
sorry the uh i watched the first uh
episode i think just the first episode
uh have you ever seen the boys no the
superhero show yeah
and in like the first few minutes
there's just like a ton of sex and then
i was like it didn't do anything for the
story at all
you know i was like i get it never does
like we're sitting here and they're like
you know it does something for the guy
who made the story that's why he put it
in there exactly yeah i guess like
there's like a scene that didn't even
need to happen it happens all the time
yeah i know it was like what was what
was that namaste even even in films that
like even in films where you know two
people having sex was important to the
plot it's you never need to show it it's
very interesting that they choose to so
often
yeah yeah well it's it's clear to me
that they just want it to be borderline
pornographic just to draw the eyes and
the clicks or whatever because
as far as i can tell in this culture sex
means nothing which is incredibly sad to
me but i i think there's a i think
there's a deeper question in you know
why why do humans have these hookups and
then regret it in the morning why is
that such a common thing that's they
still feel shame yeah like why
interesting if you hook up with like a
girl that's your friend that you're not
attracted to when you're both drunk and
then the next morning you're like oh god
what have i done i've changed the
dynamic of my relationship that's the
only shame i've ever felt walking out of
a girl's house but every other time it's
like hell yeah well so when when we
drink you know it almost kind of
for lack of a better word sort of
disables our executive love which is the
part of ourselves that you know thinks
about future consequences and things
like that i think that matters you know
and also of course when in when it's a
hookup situation you know one person is
usually kind of
pouring on the charm right so you know
she's laughing at all of his jokes he's
telling her how good she looks right and
they're both making a little bit of a
concerted effort to to get into each
other's pants right so it's almost like
they're kind of on a drug of euphoria in
that moment and then the next morning
when you know reality sets in
and lydia to your point about shame as
well just i want to back you up on that
there's a psychological healthy function
of shame which is to let us know when we
have broken our own boundaries and
broken our own standards there's
actually a healthy sense of um of when
we've come up short that's that serves
to guide us that we need to make a
change there was a viral story at a
college a poster was put up that said if
you are both drunk then like if you are
a man and you and the women are drunk
and you both hook up you raped her right
which is so insulting to women you know
what i mean because basically what that
is saying is that i need a chaperone if
i'm going to go out and have drinks you
know like that's where that goes it
means that i'm not able to just choose
anymore like how much to drink and when
i'm ready to go home with somebody i
mean i'm married now so i'm just
speaking
i'm pretty sure there was a story where
um yeah i i vaguely remember this i
think reason reported it amanda woman
both got drunk and hooked up at a
college and the man immediately went to
the school and reported her for raping
him and she got in trouble and they were
all freaking out and there's like that's
that's the way the game works he was
worried that she was gonna go and report
him so he reported her first and then he
wins because he reported her first
that's interesting but yeah i did want
to say i do think that the fact that a
woman can't have a few drinks and
maintain her bodily autonomy when i
started hearing about kids who are able
to change their gender at the drop of a
hat i was like this is so insulting that
i can't go out and have a beer and then
sleep
not that i ever would i would never i
never had and now i'm married so it's
fine but it's like
that you would have no bodily autonomy
just by the mere act of drinking a few
drinks is ridiculous to me is treating
women like children and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you